good morning like to thank the
the organizers for the invitation to
speak today
on the work that we've been doing on rna
splicing
and ancestry-related molecular targets
in precision oncology
and cancer disparities so let's talk for
just a
moment about cancer health disparities
these are the government
definitions of health disparities a
particular type of health difference
closely linked with social or economic
disadvantage
the nci's definition is below adverse
differences in cancer incidents
prevalence
cancer death survivorship burden of
cancer
or related health conditions among
specific populations
i've been working in this field for
quite a few years and i have my own
definition
the unequal burden of cancer among
racially
and ethnically diverse minorities the
medically vulnerable
and underserved we know now that this
problem is local
regional national and global
and i think this talk is perhaps
timely at this moment given the
national and international recognition
of the magnitude and impact of
health disparities in our field cancer
health disparities
so to give you a sense of what
disparities look like
this is a focus on prostate cancer
at incidence rates and death rates
there's good news and bad news in this
slide
um the good news is overall incidence
and mortality rates are going down
but the bad news is that difference
between the red line
and all of the other lines um uh
illustrates the difference in incidence
and mortality uh among
african-american men compared to
caucasian and other
uh uh racial and ethnic uh populations
well what does that look like in
clinical or biological terms
it means earlier mean age diagnosis
shorter mean survival
more common advanced stage diagnosis
greater risk of early biochemical
recurrence
and more common metastases
what we've also learned is each tumor
type and each subtype
of each tumor exhibits its own nuances
with respect to disparities in
incidence aggressiveness outcomes and
mortality
to give you a sense of the magnitude of
that disparity in prostate cancer on the
left is incidence rates and you can see
a 1.6 fold increased incidence rate
among blacks compared to whites
and on the right you see mortality
rights rates with a particularly
startling statistic
a 5.1 fold difference in mortality
rates between blacks and asian pacific
islanders
so you can see with prostate cancer
this disparity is quite dramatic
well what are some of the contributors
to cancer disparities
some people use the words determinants
of health or determinants of disparities
and we know that disparities are driven
by
a multi-level multi-factorial group of
contributors
including social and environmental um
aspects
like personal health beliefs
socioeconomics
environmental exposures
lifestyle issues like smoking status
diet
exercise obesity comorbidities in the
physical environment
structural issues for example are health
systems
access to care policy
both local state and federal
structural racism and implicit bias
within the health system
but we also know now that there is a
biological contribution to cancer health
disparities
which includes germline somatic
differences in in tumors
uh genomic epigenomic transcriptomic
proteomic and metabolomic differences
based on population
and today i'm going to be focusing on
the biological aspects of disparities
but i want to make sure that everyone is
clear
that these biological effects
or aspects occur
in conjunction with social environmental
lifestyle
and structural determinants of cancer
health disparities
and one of the most exciting
developments in science right now is
that this multi-level
these multi-level contributors to
disparities illustrate the need
for new methodologies in
intersectionality
and what's called convergence science
developing methodologies to understand
how these various
multi-level contributors impact each
other whether they mitigate
or exacerbate cancer disparities
well when we talk about biology and race
and cancer disparities it's very
important to
um to quickly point out that race in and
of itself
is not a biological construct race and
ethnicity are sociocultural constructs
however racial ancestry as a function of
the human diaspora
whether the optional or forced in the
context of slavery
affects cultural phenotypic genetic
diversity
and therefore disease risk biology
and outcomes so again it in and of
itself it's not a biological construct
but as humans spread out around the
planet our phenotypes change
and those phenotypes were dictated by g
by our genotypes
and the genotypes dictate our
susceptibility to different diseases
around the world um the biology of that
disease
and differential outcomes as well so
addre to address these complexities some
years ago i
developed a vision for disparities
impacting translational research that i
call
trenches benches bedsides and wrenches
where the trench is the community where
we can actually learn from the community
what the most
important issues and problems are we
translate that information to the bench
and of course that can be either the wet
lab or
epidemiology or outcomes research
and then that we want that information
as we learn we want to translate to the
bedside which would
improve treatment but gradually we want
to move
the information back to the community
but in our model we view it we
we move it back to the community via
policy
because we want to not only change um
uh the um minutia of the disease we want
to
change society so that we can impact
um all of those contributors to
disparities
and so this is where we use the word
wrench
just because it rhymes with trench and
we use it to refer to policy
well this is what um our laboratory
actually looks like
this is an arc that stretches from
tissue and blood specimens
collected from patients of different
racial and ethnic groups
a focus on the biology and today i'm
focusing
very specifically on rna splicing we gen
we utilize a number of different systems
s i rnas crispr small molecules splice
switching oligonucleotides
we generate cell lines p xenographs and
pdx's from patients
from different racial and ethnic groups
with the ultimate goal of conducting
and we have ongoing active race
or ethnicity stratified clinical trials
with
associated correlative science we have
an umbrella
biobanking protocol called gencade which
stands for
the genomics of cancer disparities
we're also interested in education we
want to be training the next generation
of disparities researchers
and i hear i'm just showing that i'm pi
with kevin williams to a p20 apache
grant
from the nci uh which links nc
nci designated comprehensive cancer
centers to historically black
universities and our partners at
nccu here in durham and these are just
some pictures of our scholars
we have two projects we're going working
on prostate and inflammatory breast
cancer
in african americans and we just
recently were awarded a p20 score
on cancer disparities with two projects
also two projects lung cancer and
stomach cancer
disparities and this is just a snapshot
of my lab
and i'll be talking about the work from
these post docs
um shown here april devoe muthana alabo
tyler allen john porsky joabodura
wegerman the lab is co-run by myself
dan george on the left but the person
who really makes it happen is right in
the middle
dr jennifer friedman is an astoundingly
brilliant
genomicist and she runs the day-to-day
um
operations and scientific directions of
the lab so i hope you can see that we
not only
talk about uh disparities and diversity
and inclusion but we
uh walk the walk and have an exceedingly
uh
exciting and fun diver slap
so let's get back to splicing how did we
arrive at splicing so we started this
work um
early in the ought years and
first reported differentially methylated
genes and prostate tissues from
african-american and caucasian men in
clinical cancer research
and then androgen-recepted target genes
and african-american prostate cancer
disparities published in prostate cancer
and then another paper in ccr on
identification and functional validation
of
micro rna mrna pairings and
african-american prostate cancer
disparities
and that culminated in a nature
communications paper in 2017
entitled alternative splicing promotes
tumor aggressiveness and drug resistance
in african-american prostate cancer so
we're going to do a deep dive into
splicing and i want to start first with
splicing 101 because i'm always um
intrigued to discover how many of my
colleagues have forgotten
the splicing lecture from from biology
101
so this is just a quick reminder that at
the dna level our genes
are discontinuous they include exons and
introns
the um during transcription a pre-mrna
is the first rna made it includes both
exons and introns
the introns have to be spliced out this
process was discovered in 1977 called
alternative rna splicing
and this is the process by which about
20 000 genes in the human genome produce
about 250 250 000 proteins
and by splicing different exons together
you can produce
multiple different proteins from the
same gene each with a different function
we know it drives evolutionary
biological diversity
and therefore likely drives
tumor-related biological diversity
and we know that the function of
proteins produced from these variants
can be dramatically different as though
as if they were
um made from different genes entirely
and just as an example i'll just show
you um uh
one example from the uh mcl
gene and if you look there it comes up
in
the red box and what you can see is just
the removal or the alternative splicing
of a single exon
can convert that gene from a
pro-apoptotic to
an anti-apoptotic gene and we now know
that splicing
impacts every single one of the major
hallmarks of cancer
so splicing is very important and it is
regulated by a combination of cis-acting
splicing elements
at the dna level um usually right at the
junctions between the exons and introns
and a
vast machinery at last count nearly 500
different
transacting splicing factors which
interact
with the cis acting splicing elements
in the pre-mrna exactly duplicate it
from the
from the dna
excuse me and those two
work together to regulate splicing so
our lab is interested in answering
questions like what drives alternative
rna splicing
how does it affect tumor biology can
splicing
help predict risk or survival is it
clinically meaningful
and is it targetable well over the
course of today's talk i'm going to
cover
uh five different aspects of splicing
and and the first one is the
differential burden of splicing between
normal tissue and cancer tissue
and between cancer of different
ancestors is larger than expected
and more complex than expected so this
slide
harkens back to the nature
communications paper
this work originated at the george
washington cancer center
in collaboration with my colleague dr
norman lee
and vidar wang who was then a
postdoctoral fellow
and is now on faculty at the university
of maryland eastern shore
and all i'm showing you here is the
principal component analysis
of an exxon array and what you can see
by looking at the blue circles in the
red circles
is a dramatic bifurcation between black
and white
prostate cancer samples as a function of
exon
arrays so because this is an exon array
it pointed us
almost immediately to this issue of
splicing
and and whether and what the magnitude
of splicing differences might be between
the two races
so on this slide you can see that we
were actually
quite shocked to see the magnitude so on
the left
in prostate cancer we found more than 2
500 differentially
spliced genes as a function of
self-identified
race compared to about 1200
differentially expressed genes as a
function of race
with 290 genes overlapping and
interestingly out of the 2500
differentially expressed genes
that were different by race 644 of them
were also present in the patient's
adjacent normal prostate tissue
suggesting that there may be ancestry
related splice variants
that are carried forward from normal
tissue into tumor tissue
and may actually contribute to the
biology of the cancer
on the right on this slide just shows
another analysis that we've done with
lung cancer in this case squamous cell
uh lung carcinoma and here you see
nearly
5 000 race related differentially
splashed genes
and in both of these you can see that a
large proportion of these splice
variants
are either generally implicated in
cancer or
are actually in drivers oncogenes or
tumor suppressor genes
so these striking results motivated us
to expand the analysis
to a computational approach to identify
the
splicing events among tumors that
exhibit
disparities between black and white
patients and we
did a deep analysis of tcga spicy
datasets
of all ars and alternative
transcription events for all samples in
tcga
these are the tumor types breast
cervical colon liver
lung adeno lung squamous pancreatic
prostate
and uterine and you can see a varying
degree
of of number of samples from african
americans
pointing out again this issue of the
low participation
of ethnic and racial minorities in
clinical trials in this case biobanking
trials
which is something that's attracting
enormous attention worldwide
right now
so here what i'm showing is the
identification of race related
alternative rna splicing events
and alternative transcription events in
tcga
and the red and blue dots collectively
are
the top 500 or the top ranked
alternative splicing events the top 500
by race
so those those two grouped together and
then below
in just the red alone are the top
alternative
race related alternative rna splicing
events that
exhibit an absolute delta psi
of greater than 15 percent between black
and white patients
with an adjusted p-value of less than
.05
delta psi stands for the change in
percent spliced in and that is a
computational tool that
that simply reflects the degree of
splicing
within any particular gene so you can
see that there are both
blue and red dots associated with each
of these tumor types so each of these
dots refers to a gene
and you can begin to analyze and
quantify
the number of genes that show splice
variation and you can do
interesting computational analyses like
in this case a venn diagram looking at
overlap between
breast lung adeno lung squamous
colorectal and prostate cancer so in
this
interesting analysis you can see 18
genes are actually in common between
these five different tumor types and you
can see
an example here of what those genes are
so these are alternatively spliced in a
race related fashion
in common to five different tumor types
we also were able to look at the top
seven not just five tumor types but
ten i'm sorry nine cancer types
and the top seven race related
differences
um in splicing among all nine types and
here you can see those genes and you can
see like for example
in the red box ulk three a dramatic
difference in expression of
of splice variants across
all of the tumor types
and then we were able to do pathway
analysis oncogenic pathway analysis
and here what you can see is all nine
tumor types
and quite interesting um and surprising
we were able to find um a number of
pathways cancer-related pathways in
common
that should between these tumor types
that showed race related differential
splicing
in particularly the interphone
interferon alpha response
interferon gamma response and
inflammatory responses in general
and then also quite interesting
the mtor signaling pathway showed
race related splice variation um
in in in common uh with multiple
tumor types
so um just to go
a little um in a little bit more detail
sorry i'm not sure what's happening with
this particular slide
it's taking a moment to load we're also
able to show differential
race related splicing events in this
case associated with prostate cancer
as a function of disease free survival
probability
the blue dots show differential splicing
with higher psi
in black versus white patients where
it's associated with poorer disease
research
survival the yellow dots show decreased
psi
in white patients associated with poor
disease free survival
and so you can see sema a6
a well-known prostate cancer associated
gene
xosc9 as risk factors for
african-americans and then xrcc4
and c3a5 are
as risk factors for uh for white
patients as well and here i'm just
showing that we're able to conduct that
analysis
um across various tumor types and we
don't
we won't dig into the details but if you
look in the upper right
you can see some very interesting genes
bcl2
fox pham sc3h these are all
genes that are well known in association
with various cancers
showing differential race related
splicing as a function of
different survival probability
well one of the questions that
frequently comes up when you study
splicing
is are the splice variants functional
and here we're simply showing that
somewhere between 72
and 82 of the splice variants that we
find
in tcga are in frame and therefore
are expected to be um able to be
translated
into variant proteins
so in summary from this computational
approach
we identified a large number of race
related splicing
differences between black and white
patients
a large number of the race related
splicing differences overlapped across
cancer types
and the race related splicing
differences were determined to function
in oncogenic pathways
and were associated with black or white
white
cancer patient survival to go a little
bit further
we actually built a new computational
tool it's an
interactive and user-friendly web app to
enable researchers to mine
data such as tcga in the context of race
or ethnicity and it's called duke
can splice and this is just a screen
shot of of cans flies
and here what you're able to see is you
can choose your tumor type
up at the top you can choose whether you
want to analyze
splicing aggregate gene expression
correct correlations between the two
or survival you can pick your gene name
you can pick
what which splicing variants you want to
look at in this case i've selected
all and then you can analyze each splice
variant as a function
of differential expression as a function
of race
you can also move on to aggregate gene
expression
and in this case um
again it's a little slow to to load you
can input your gene name
and then you can look now in this
example across
different tumor types and compare
between the tumor types
and you can look at differential variant
expression expression
as a function of race and then finally
you can look at survival
um and in this case you can choose your
gene
you can select exactly which splice
um variant you want to look at
you can look at a km plot for
differences in survival
and an interactive output
of the selected splice variant and the
gene encoding the selected splice
variant
as a function of survival so cansplice
is a user-friendly
interactive web tool that allows you to
analyze splicing as a function of race
and ethnicity
aggregate gene expression correlation
with aggregate expression
and association with survival
probability
and here i'm just showing you um the
portal
that can splice can be
access through so we were also as i
mentioned to you
um there um in addition to the cis
acting splice elements
um splicing factors transacting splicing
factors
are involved in regulating splicing and
we were able to look at
differential expression of splicing
factors
as a function of race between black and
white patients
here you can see all nine tumor types
and then within breast you can see the
sub analysis basal
her2 lume a loom b versus normal
and in prostate you can see in gleason
score
and we were able to identify a number of
splicing factors that show
a full change greater than 1.5 with an
adjusted p-value of 0.05
that differ between race
as a function of race and this is an
example
the s n r n 7
protein binds to the u1 spliceosomal rna
forming the u1's sn rnp core element of
the spliceosome
and this is just one example of the
analysis comparing
whites and yellow and blacks in blue and
this is looking at breast cancer and
breast cancer subtypes
and you can see very dramatic
differences in the
expression of this splicing factor as a
function of race um
and in these subtypes of breast cancer
okay the second part ancestry related
ars
drives important features of the
hallmark of cancer
as well as drug resistance and can be
both predictive and
prognostic and this is right out of the
nature communications paper
so i won't dwell on this but very
briefly
if you look in the upper left you can
see in the african-american patients
both a long form and a short form
frequently showing up in samples from
african-american
prostate cancer patients compared to
those from european americans where
the amount the ratio and the frequency
of the short form is dramatically less
and this was statistically significant
in the lower left what we did is create
sirna that very specifically targets the
um the splice isoform that's dominant in
white patients which includes exon 20.
in prostate cancer from black patients
very more frequently exon 20 is spliced
out
but when we use an sirna to exon 20
and we treat a cell line
isolated from white cancer patients it
markedly decreases
the migration and invasiveness but when
we knock that long form out
which allows the short form to become
the dominant form
invasion and migration and migration and
invasion actually
increases in the cell line derived from
african-american patients
and on the other side um in that
quadrant
you see that if we design an sirna um
to just the short form it has no impact
on the cell line derived from white
patients because
that short that form isn't present but
it actually decreases um
invasion um of these the uh
cell line derived from a black patient
showing that the short form
actually drives uh tumor the
aggressiveness of this line in culture
we then took the cells in vivo and um
it turns out that the short form exon 20
actually codes for the binding site for
a drug
called cal 101 or indelisib
uh and and what you can
see here is that the um uh
when we over express the lung form
versus the short form
we drive tumor formation but in the
presence of cal 101
when the long form is driving two more
formation it's inhibited by the drug
but when the short form is driving to
formation there's no
impact of the drug which makes sense
because the drug binding site is no
longer present in the messenger rna
and then finally you can mine tcga and
you can do a deep dive
on p i three k delta
and you can look at the short form
versus the long form
and in this chart you can see that
whenever the short form
the ratio of the short to the long form
is longer is
is more extensive survival is lower
all of which together means that the
short form
which is the dominant form expressed in
african-american prostate cancer
actually drives
a more aggressive form of the disease
well in this slide what i'm showing you
is that if you go back
to exon array analysis and you
combine data from prostate
breast lung and liver cancer in this
example you can do
all these men these computational
analysis computational approaches
you can mix and match any tumor type but
in this group
we found it quite interesting that a
number of very
interesting and important genes show
race related
uh differential splicing in common to
these four different tumor types
that includes the insulin receptor cd44
integrins uh extracellular matrix
uh proteases fibronectin collagen genes
but one particular gene caught one of
our postdocs attention muthana alabo
and he did a deep dive into the lm07
gene
which is a limb domain seven gene that
modulates actin
signaling and in this particular gene
the
um the splicing difference as a function
of race
is a skip of exon 12. so muthana did
some remarkable work and use crispr
to very selectively and specifically
knock out just exon 12
not knock out the entire gene just that
one
exon in the entire gene and when you
knock out exon 12
we find a dramatic increase in migration
and invasion in these in the cell line
in this case gu145
so just losing this one small exon exon
12
markedly promotes the aggressiveness of
uh
of these tumor cells uh indicating that
this one exon has a suppressive effect
on metastatic potential so we went back
to tcga which is all primary cancer
and very interestingly we found no
difference in the expression of lm07
between normal
and tumor tissue but then we looked at
the stand up to cancer
cohort of prostate cancer which is all
metastatic
and there we found a very large
difference in the frequency
of loss of expression of lmo7 so what
you can see
on the left side of the right chart is
the majority of
a metastatic the more metastatic the
tumor
the more frequent you find loss of lmo7
so if you go back in analyze
computationally
you can see on the left if you just look
at
high lmo7 versus low lmo7
whenever the lm07 is low you have worse
outcomes
and on the right if you do an analysis
of
lmo7 as a function of exon 12
its presence or its absence whenever
exon 12
is uh it is absent
you have um worse survival outcomes
okay the next section is
ancestry-related mutations and splice
regulatory dna sequences are more common
than expected and functionally important
and here i'm just going to reference two
papers that we've published one in ijc
and one in carcinogenesis
both showing that um sniffs
single nucleotide polymorphisms in the
splice regulatory
regions of stemness related genes
correlate with racial disparities in
susceptibility to prostate cancer
and they also correlate with survival in
prostate cancer
and these are just some of the genes
where those sniffs were detected
tp63 ald 1a1
win1 met 1 egfr cd44
and gdf 15. we also did an analysis
of the the large
cohort of known prostate cancer related
genes and we found snips in splice
regulatory regions in
klk3 which happens to be pspsa
atm mtor mpi 3k delta
and then we also did the analysis um
genome-wide
and these are some of the interesting
genes where we found
race-related snips in rna splice
regulatory regions
of some very important genes atpase
hypoxia inducible factor methyl
transferase
uh cytotoxicity triggering receptor 2
pbx
and trem l4 all of which are involved in
cancer okay the fourth one
alternative rna splicing and ancestry
relating ars is targetable
both at the level of splice variant
proteoforms and splicing itself
and here i'm just going to show one
example
of some work we've done and on the left
here you see
that our approach is to create splice
switching oligonucleotides um in
in a very real sense these are antisense
oligonucleotides but they are
targeted very specific to splice
junctions and very unique sequences
um in and around the splice junction so
they're called splice switching all of
the nucleotides
and you can use these to interact with
the pre-mrna in a way that you can
toggle
back and forth between splice variants
and
on the right on this slide i'm just
going to show you one example of one
that we've
uh we've done extensive work on we've
designed an sso
to the ce3 exon
of the androgen receptor which
is involved in the production of a
pathological
variant of uh of the androgen receptor
called arv7
and the arv7 when is it when it's
expressed
correlates with the development of
resistance to hormone therapy so in this
example
we're showing that an sso that targets
the arv-7
markedly decreases arv-7 rna and protein
expression and it does so that's shown
on the left
in the middle we're showing that it does
that without
um impacting the expression of the full
length androgen receptor
the the physiological androgen receptor
and that's very important because on the
far right on this slide
what you can see is we have shown that
this
sso decreases proliferation and it
restores
sensitivity to ends ludamine hormone
therapy
and that would not be possible if all
the sss
if all the sso did is simply knock down
the entire antigen receptor and every
variant including the full-length one
so this shows the level of cell activity
and the fact that we can actually
restore
androgen receptor sensitivity to these
tumor cells
okay um uh in the
number five ancestry related ars
influences pathways
uh related to immuno oncology and may
drive neoandrogen production
and i'm just gonna show one slide here
uh we've done
a deep dive into immune related pathways
um in this i'm just showing a couple of
examples one in prostate and one
in lung squamous cell carcinoma and you
can see that
for both of these we have discovered um
a number of race related alternatively
spliced genes
that are involved in adaptive immunity
innate immunity nf kappa b
signaling inflammatory pathway um
interleukin signaling uh and defense
path
responses to both bacteria and viruses
so we're
in the process now of analyzing this uh
at a much deeper level and looking at
its biological function
as well so those were the five
examples that i wanted to show you and i
just want to end with
two more slides um to illustrate
how important we think some of these
discoveries may be
and how important it is for us
as a cancer community to really
stress the emphasis uh and the
importance of conducting
ancestry stratified clinical trials we
do this in the context of splicing but
we
we certainly strongly encourage
this for all cancer-related clinical
trials
and just to illustrate how important
this is
i'm showing here four different trials
in prostate cancer
abby race which is avaradoran stratified
by avarador on prednisone stratified by
race
conducted here at duke at the duke
cancer institute
dan george is the pi the proceed trial
which is tip t
stratified by race the pi was oliver
starter down in louisiana
but duke was actually the largest
accruer to this trial
dose of taxal study this was a
retrospective meta-analysis
uh conducted by susan halaby uh here at
duke
and then the ongoing panther trial which
is apolludamide abaraderone
and prednisone stratified by race which
is in progress so i can't talk about it
but the first three something quite
dramatic has happened
in all three of these trials hormone
therapy
and immunocellular immunotherapy and
chemotherapy
three different modalities three
different types of analyses
african-american men came into these
trials with worse disease
by by multiple biochemical and clinical
indica
indicators and in each one responded
better to therapy in some cases
markedly better to therapy and i can't
think
of a better impetus and exhortation
for us as translational scientists and
physicians
um uh to um to really um
uh increasingly stress the importance of
conducting
oncology clinical trials that are
stratified by race and ethnicity
so we'll end by um just a a cartoon
that's in a um a commentary that we
published in clinical cancer research
last year
on the left is a tumor cell from one
ancestral population
on the right is the tumor cell from
another ancestral population
we're just trying to indicate that at
the level of dna
there may be biomarkers as a function of
the snips
that i talked about with respect to the
circular the transacting factors
you can see differences on the left and
right sn
uh sf1 uh times two
uh and then the different ratio in the
uh in the other
uh cell uh on the right uh you can see
the pre-mrnas being made and the
different splice variants being made
as a function of the combination
of cis-acting elements and transacting
elements you can see
i'm stressing here that neoandrogens can
be produced by
these different splice variants
biomarkers can also be produced at the
proteoform level and that you can target
um splicing both with therapeutic small
ssos and therapeutic small molecules
as well as begin to really
explore the universe of proteoforms that
is
protein variant coded for by these
different splice variants
for sensitivity to um to small molecules
okay it takes a lot of people um to do
this kind of work
and so here i've already acknowledged my
laboratory team but we can't do this
work without our clinical partners both
in gu and in lung
uh clinical partners in med-onc and
surgeon surgical oncology
here my key duke collaborators our
clinical research team or actually
consenting the patients
and of course we thank the patients
themselves our shared resources
supported by the duke cancer institute
especially the biospecimen repository
team and my
outside collaborators and it also takes
a lot of money to do these kinds of
this kind of research so we have
multiple grants from the nci
i mentioned earlier the p20 apache grant
with nccu
the the um the p20 disparity score grant
multiple r01s we have a
2018 challenge award from the prostate
cancer foundation
with movember foundation funding
we have three dod grants
from the congressionally directed
medical research program
department of defense both in prostate
and lung cancer
and then grants from the v foundation
the murdock study
peter michael foundation and several
internal grants from
the duke cancer institute as well so
thank you for your attention
and i'll stop there